so covid hits
first time i went to california since
covid was june of
2021. so over a year into covid but you
know they still hadn't met they had it
was not like florida so i so i'm out
there doing stuff like fun all this
stuff and i told myself i'm like look
i'm not wearing a mask
i'm going to do my thing so you put me
wherever you want to put me but just
understand i don't want any
confrontation or anything but this is
i'm going to live like i live in florida
so i get there first day i'm there i'm
waiting the cars are coming to pick me
up i'm on the curb these two guys in
mass come scurrying over to me i'm like
oh god here we go
so as a new floridian one of the things
that's constantly on my mind is what can
i do for this state and i really mean
that what can i do for this state that i
i feel like a refugee i am a refugee it
it
it
i genuinely feel like i came from
another country and thank god you guys
speak english here that's basically
that's basically where i'm at but so
what do we do what do we do to defend
florida because the more that florida
does it right the more that the machine
whether that's the media or the
political machine or just the elite
machine whatever you want to call it the
more it is going to stare down you stare
down these folks what do we do to just
keep this state right
well i think it's a great question
before i answer just let me say this
about california so um first time you
got to put money in the jar man that's
the deal
so covid hits
first time i went to california since
covid was june of
2021. so over a year into covid but you
know they still hadn't met they had it
was not like florida so i so i'm out
there doing stuff like fun all this
stuff and i told myself i'm like look
i'm not wearing a mask
i'm going to do my thing so you put me
wherever you want to put me but just
understand i don't want any
confrontation or anything but this is
i'm going to live like i live in florida
so i get there first day i'm there i'm
waiting the cars are coming to pick me
up i'm on the curb these two guys in
mass come scurrying over to me i'm like
oh god here we go
one guy gets right in front of me pulls
down his mask looks me right in the eye
and says i wish you were our governor
put on the mask and left so
you never know
and so it was interesting
um
but what i would say is
when you're looking at
big time fail buddy big time fail
[Applause]
you know part of what we're doing i
think now is we've been able to create
so much momentum
that like 2018 election
very close call for the state of florida
when i got elected because if i had not
gotten elected many of you none of you
who moved here would have moved here and
some of you that lived here probably
would have moved away
just the truth
but
when i got elected we had almost 300 000
more registered democrats in the state
of florida than republicans and we never
had had more registered republicans in
florida prior to me becoming governor
well
negative 300 000 november of 2018 june
1st 2022 we have 150 000 more registered
republicans
now
so i i think that that is uh telling us
that we have an opportunity uh to really
solidify the direction that the state's
going uh this november and so i would
say you know my election very important
and we just need a massive turnout and i
think we can get it you know people will
come up to me who you can tell are not
super political and they'll thank me for
saving their job they'll thank me for
saving their kids education they'll
thank me for saving their business and
they want to be helpful so we have an
opportunity to do that and i think that
that's absolutely critical but i also
think we've got a lot of great people
that have moved in here i mean you look
at like you know down in miami you know
miami is like this i mean first of all
it's never boom the way it's booming but
it's moving right and there aren't very
many urban environments in this country
that are really moving right and you
know part of it is the is the
demographics i mean you know you look at
like our hispanic communities there are
conservative and they want to make sure
that this country doesn't repeat the
mistakes of these other countries in
latin america where you had marxism take
over cuba venezuela all these other
places and so i think particularly with
you guys in south florida because it
used to be
south florida would be like huge blue
you know then you'd have pockets of blue
orlando gainesville whatever and the
rest would either be really red or maybe
kind of purple and now south florida is
becoming much more conservative and i
think that that's largely i think it's
too i do think it's a result of the
migration and i think it's a reaction
against brandon's policies which let's
be honest
have not been terribly successful
you know i did the budget thing today we
were at the villages and i and i just
point out there's news reports recent
news reports he's so frustrated that his
approval ratings are in the toilet and
he's lashing out at his staff blaming
this blaming that and i'm just thinking
to myself
you have a situation where
you know you came in
and oh by the way for for any more of
those people that are out here we're not
gonna let them take away your
constitutional rights
not gonna happen
but but you have so so but brandon he's
lashing out blaming other people and i'm
just thinking to myself man
you want to know why your approval
ratings are in the toilet look in the
mirror
your policies are failing people don't
want to pay 475 a gallon for gas and
it's gonna be over five dollars very
soon they don't want a war against
domestic american energy you know for
some reason with biden if you beg maduro
for oil that's somehow not global
warming but if we produce our own then
it's global warming give me a break what
a farce and so
he's creating a lot of these problems
and here's the here i mean i'd say
between brandon and and kovid i think
there's a lot of voters out there who
are who have reevaluated maybe some of
how they voted some people just vote one
way or another maybe their parents were
republicans so they were democrats or
whatever now people are starting to look
wait a minute do i want to be with a
party if this guy's the leader do i want
to be a part of a party that says i
don't have a right to earn a living
unless i take boosters every time fauci
tells me to do i want to be a part do i
want to be a part of a party that
doesn't believe we should have control
over our territory and our borders like
you see what's going on in the southern
border and i think a lot of people are
saying you know what that's not for me
so it gives us an opportunity i think to
build a stronger movement here and i
think the southern florida is going to
be absolutely huge to the future of the
state
[Applause]
well first i just want to say that i
love that you keep calling him brandon
because
i think it's possible he thinks his name
is brandon
so that's pretty beautiful also i wasn't
going to do this the end we only have
one more quest time for one more
question but i wanted to give you a
let's go brandon t-shirt it seems
that he should put it on right now and
rip it off hulk hogan style
all right one more for you
sort of on that bravery thing that we
talked about before and where that comes
from within you and all these people
that are out here and as we watch this
thing happen and watch the media come
after you and all of that stuff
what else can they do to fight what else
can they do what can empower them to
just be part of this thing and keep this
state right keep this country right and
go on well one of the things the points
i'll make and obviously i mention
biden's failures a lot
and relative and deservedly so but
here's the thing
i could deal with that if in exchange i
could have a conservative majority on
every school board in america for
example um
what you can do at the local level
uh to really be involved in your
community particularly with these
schools because i think that we've led a
lot at the state level you know making
sure that that obviously the young kids
you know aren't having the sexuality
involved in the gender ideology also
making sure uh that we don't have things
like critical race theory and all these
ideologies and that's important
but really it's the parents and the
people that are running for school board
and all these other things and so yes i
obviously made a plug for my election i
think it's very important but i think
the school board elections have more
importance than ever before
you guys can make a huge difference in
your community
and you know the moms have done great
and the parents are energized like never
before and they should be really leading
the effort but you know what you don't
even have to have kids in the school
system to be concerned about what's
going on with education because if you
if we do our job right and we're doing
you know good solid education i think
you need to have things like we've
pushed in florida american civics
understanding the constitution
understanding all those things
if we're providing a solid foundation
for education rather than having these
systems become centers of indoctrination
you are going to be we are going to be
so much better off as a state than a lot
of these other places if you're looking
for more honest and thoughtful
conversations about politics instead of
non-stop yelling check out our politics
playlist and if you want to watch full
interviews on a variety of topics watch
our full episode playlist all right over
here and to get notified of all future
videos be sure to subscribe and click
the notification bell